well hello everyone thank you for
joining this webinar this session is
going to be about get just to check -
that you are on the on the right session
and yeah let's just go right ahead if
you have any questions you can write
them on slide oh and I'll reserve some
time at the end to answer them alright
let's get started my name is Enrico
campidoglio I work as a freelancer this
is me freelancing from home especially
these days but we're not here to talk
about me we are here to talk about git
and in particular we want to see that so
we know that learning it today is pretty
easy you know there are books there are
online courses there are tutorials
hectare 11 podcasts about git so you can
safely say that it has never been a
better time to learn it
however while everybody is busy telling
you how it works there there isn't that
much guidance about how to use git
well while you're working with others
but you know it's like learning to play
the piano so you you learn how to play
individual notes but then you're not
able to play a full song so what we need
is guidance help but then you might
wonder ok why'd why would you need help
in using a version control system
and you might be right asking that
question because you know traditional
source control systems like CVS and
perforce subversion and even TFS they
were they were pretty much telling you
how to use them by virtue of their
design so you didn't really have that
much choice on how to do version control
it was dictated by the version control
system get on the other hand doesn't
really tell you how to use it it's it
says it's writing to in the in the name
it is just a Content tracker
it doesn't really care how you you use
it in the context of a version control
system so it's more like whatever works
for you and this leaves a wide gap in in
how in how people are using it because
there is no defined way but then the
question becomes okay
if there is no well-defined way to use
git and you can use it pretty much any
way you like how do you know that you're
using it properly or how do you know
that you're getting the most value out
of it well the only thing you can do is
observe what others are doing with git
what works for them and see if any of
that applies to you and this is exactly
what I've done for like for a few years
now I've been working with lots of
different teams and lots of different
projects and I've observed how different
ways of using git has impacted these
teams and these projects and I've been
basically writing writing this all down
because it's good stuff and the kind of
overtime distilled it into a set of
guidance so what is this talk about
this talk is about equal a collection of
habits and ideas that I've collected
from working with people who are really
good at using it to improve the workflow
and when I talk about using it I don't
mean just in the context of a team but
also on an individual level so these are
habits and ideas they work both
individually and as a group so let's get
started so I just mentioned that you can
use get a kind of at two levels on your
own like on your own machine and while
collaborating with others so it makes
sense to divide these ideas and habits
and techniques into two kinds the what I
call personal workflows there is things
you do with get when you are on your own
machine and things that you do while you
are working with others in a team so
throughout this presentation I've been
I'll be dividing what I talk about into
these two categories and to be more
specific I'll give you three techniques
or habits that you can use on your own
individually and then I'll give you
three ideas things to think about in the
context of a team while you are deciding
how you want to use kit in your project
so in total six ideas and let's start
with the individual workflows so let me
jump over what I have here I have slides
on the right well my right might be your
left so we just keep that in mind and on
the other on the other side I have a
terminal let me just briefly mention
that I'll be using it from the command
line throughout this presentation
however most of the things I'll be
talking about they apply just as well if
you're use
get from a graphical user interface and
when I talk about something that only
applies to the command line I'll I'll
say it
so the first habit or a good thing to do
at a individual level well using we'd
get is to get comfortable now we know
that it is a pretty complicated tool to
use already so there is no reason to
make it any harder to use than it
already is
and this means configuring it configure
your environment so that it is a
comfortable tool to use so what follows
are a series of settings that I
regularly apply on my get installation
if I'm on a new project or a new
computer and they really help using it
more effectively so the first one is and
this applies if you're using it from the
command line is to use a get aware plant
that it there are a bunch of utilities
that basically enrich your console your
shell prompt with information that are
specific to your repository like for
example which branch you're on how many
files you've changed if there are any
conflicts and these of course depend on
which command line prompt you're using
so if you're using PowerShell I'll
recommend using a utility called push
get if you are using Linux or if you're
just using Linux on Windows I am using
bash then bash get prompt is a really
good one and if you're looking for
something cross-platform then is my
personal favorite is starship and that's
what you're being looking at on the
other side on the terminal starship is a
cross-platform
Ghita where from
and as a bonus it's also written in rust
so it doesn't get any cooler than that
yeah so having a get aware prompt next
one is having some pretty dips so if
you're using it you'll be looking well
if you see source control in general
you'll be looking at a lot of disk and
it makes sense to make them as readable
as possible and this means installing a
utility that code it's called deep so
fancy it's an NPM module and what it
does is that it accepts input it accepts
a universal diff in text format and it
removes all the noise and makes it
basically pretty to look at
so let me show you what I mean after you
have installed it so you say MPM install
g diff so fancy which already done what
you do is that you configure your get
installation to basically pipe all the
diff output through this so fancy so you
say git config core it's called pager in
in get parlance and you say I'm gonna
pass it to diff so fancy and after this
Oh fancy it makes sense to page it to
something like less excuse me to give
you basically the ability to scroll up
and down in the indeed if text and what
I usually do is that I send three option
to less the first one called are this
one make it will tell less to print
control characters for example like line
endings and those things you absolutely
want to see in your diff when you're
looking at differences between two files
if just the line endings changed you
want to see that
the next one is called F and what this
does is it tells les that if the if
you're looking at fits in one screen
then you can exit immediately instead of
having you press Q every time to to exit
the third option is X and what this does
is it basically clears the screen before
printing the div so after you've done
all this you can basically say div for
example in this sample process I'm
looking at if I want to DIF the commit
that is before head
compared to head I get this let me just
show you how it looks without when you
say no pager div head so this is telling
get to just skip the pager so this is
how it usually looks like usually looks
like on the bottom part and on the top
part is through diff so fancy so if you
don't think this is fancy I don't know
what you think is fancy you see it even
highlights the exact character that
changed between the two lines while the
regular diff does not and it also
removes the plus and minus and it makes
T the header much more concise so pretty
diffs is something that effective teams
and effective get users absolutely have
the next one is and it's created - this
is making your patches more readable so
by default when you're looking at a
patch it will show you and let me let me
just show you again it will show you
exactly two lines before and after it's
change
now sometimes when you're looking at ad
if you want more context to be able to
determine a do for example which
function this line is so you can tell
get to show you more lines around each
diff by setting the diff context option
so in this case so by default you say
diphthong text the default is to if you
set it to 4 and then basically run the
same command again now you see that I
have four lines around each each the da
around the difference and this key of
course you can set it to whatever you
want and this allows you to to have more
information around its difference but I
found that for is Allah is a number that
you know doesn't make the DIF too long
but usually it's enough to to make sense
of a individual diff all right let's
move on to the next one
whitespace now as programmers we know
that no white space matters probably
much more than any other part of life so
you absolutely want to handle it
correctly and get has a bunch of
built-in functionality to do exactly
that
for example it can tell you if you have
some invalid whitespace in your source
code all you have to do is tell it what
should be considered invalid whitespace
through the core dot whitespace option
so for example I usually set it to core
whitespace I set it to blank at end of
line that means I don't want any spaces
at the end of a line I don't want any
spaces at the end of the file either and
this this is not getting into the
indentation but I don't want any tabs in
my indentation
I want you spaces instead as it should
be right
so this means that if let me just open
up the source code file here and let's
make a change let's do this we change
this to we change the string and then
we'll also add a bunch of white space at
the end all right so now you see that
starship is showing me that I have one
modified files already without having to
do git status which is pretty nice and
if I do get diff - - check having set
the core white space option it will show
me ah you have trailing white space and
it shows me exactly where in the file
now of course I have the option to fix
it but I can also just go ahead and
commit it so let's do that because I
want to show you another thing you can
do with white space you say git commit
all with the message some invalid white
space so now I've committed some invalid
white space one thing it can do for you
is that it can automatically fix any
whitespace errors by doing a rebase yre
base you might wonder well that's
because when you're doing a rebase it
will apply every change that is made in
a commit one at the time on top of the
previous commit and that's a perfect
time to make any modifications to the
source file as it applies the next
commit so in this case I want to say a
rebase and let's start - commits before
my latest one with the with the invalid
whitespace actually before we do that
let me show you how it looks like
the diff so this is the commit I just
made with the with the extra white space
here so we sue a git rebase to commit
before my latest one and then I say
white space equals fix so you see that
git has no rewinded head to two commits
ago and then it applied the latest two
commits and now if I look at my lathe
the latest one you see that the white
space is gone so yeah absolutely enable
this in your project and use it because
there's nothing worse than having real
changes mixed up with a lot of white
space errors all right next up is
conflict handling of course conflict IA
are a fact of life and especially when
you're doing source control with other
people and get has some pretty nice
built-in facilities to let you handle
conflict now by default let me show you
what I have here I have two I have two
branches now master that I'm on and then
I have one cool feature now I know that
there is a conflict in that feature
branch so let's try to merge feature on
master and I get a conflict now usually
what get will do is that it will show
you what each side of the conflict how a
particular line that is conflicting it
will show you how it looks like on
either side so you can decide you can
decide which one you want so on the one
side I have a comma here this is the
conflicting line
and the other side I don't have the
comma and they remove the exclamation
mark over here so at this point I have
to decide which one I want so this is
good in many cases but sometimes when
you are trying to decide which side of
the conflict you want to to choose it's
helpful to see how did this line look
like before the conflict so that means
how did this line look like on the
latest commit before the two that are
conflicting and the common parent so
this is called a three-way merge and
this is one of the best features in get
is that it has a really good facilities
to do a so-called three-way merge why
three-way well because you are comparing
two sides not only against each other
but you're comparing them to their
common parent so how do you do that you
tell git that you want a conflict style
you set it to d3 now by default you say
merge conflict style by default this is
set to merge which is two way merge not
three way and use we can set it to merge
dot conflict style we set it to d3 now
we just abort this this merge and we'll
do it again with the new option so a
merge feature now I still have the
conflict and the let's look at how the
file looks like now and you see that now
I have a three-way merge so not only am
i comparing the two lines but I'm also
comparing them against how it looked
like before so you see before didn't
have a comma but it had the exclamation
mark and then this side changed it by
removing the summation mark and this
side change it by removed by adding the
comma and at this point of course I can
decide how I want to
to resolve this conflict correct so
let's remove this one cool next up we
have something called global ignores
global ignore so you know that every
repository has some files that you don't
want to track and the you tell get to
what files you don't want to track by
adding them to a dot get ignore file now
this can get pretty repetitive
especially if you're working with a lot
of the same so all your projects are
using the same kind of programming
language or frameworks because they tend
to have the same kind of temp files and
files you don't want to track so a very
useful thing saying that many effective
teams do is that they define a global
ignore and they put it somewhere else on
their a file system like for example in
the home directory and then you can tell
get to read the get ignores instruction
from this global file as well as any
additional digit ignores that you put
inside a particular repository so this
is a dotnet core 3.1 project as you can
see starship is also telling me what
kind of platform I am I'm working with
in this particular project and of course
you don't want to track like the bina
knobs so let let me first show you how
this repository looks like I have like a
source directory with a program then I
have a project file now if we just build
it
so this will create a bunch of ooh not
working but let's worry about that for a
moment because we're gonna look at other
things you can do to solve these kind of
problems but so nevermind that is not
working the important thing is that it
has created bean and herbs directory
that you absolutely do not want to track
and as you can see I can see that there
are some untracked files now in my
working directory so for example the
object now object bin are common to all
those not project so this is a good
candidate to put in the global ignore
file so let's so I have it in my home
directory if you're on Windows that will
be C users and then then your username
so get ignore underscore global and
right now it just has these two files
these two entries I just tell it that I
don't want to track any bin or object
directories and never ever so I just put
them in the global one and now as you
can see I didn't have to do anything and
it just shows them as ignored and that's
because of course I set the excludes
files exclude XCore exclude files what
is it called screwed files it's called
in the global ok let me just find it
config global list grab exclude there it
is a core dot excludes file and file
sorry
and you give it the path to where it is
alright
next one is a little bit of an unknown
feature so if you're using tags if your
team are using tags to version your
software which you should it might be
frustrating that git doesn't
automatically push new tags when you do
a push operation if you want to do that
you'll have to explicitly push them or
add the follow tags option well one of
the things that I've seen most teams do
when you're working with tags is that
they enable the automatic push of new
tags by setting the config push dot
follow tags option to true and that
every time you create a brand new tag
and you do a push it will automatically
now push the commit and the title as
well so not only fans here but something
that you should be aware of okay so the
this is all the thing I showed you right
now is in the first of these three
individual workflows techniques the next
one is to craft your history so
something that I've seen effective teams
do is that they really take care of
their history that means making sure
that the history is readable and that it
clearly is a track of how the software
how the source code change throughout
the project and why it change in the way
it did so it must be a clear record of
what happened and that means creating
good commits now now you might say okay
yeah but what's a good commit well after
years of reflection I eventually arrived
at the conclusion that good commits are
acid now if you work with databases you
might recognize this acronym however
they in the contest of get it takes a
whole different meaning
so what are
seed commits well let's start with the a
the a is good commits are autonomous
that means commit shall make a logical
change that is independent from other
commits okay that makes sense but how do
you do it in practice them yeah well you
use something called a patch add or a
parts commit what does it mean for
example let's say that I want to open up
this file and I'm in this file and I'm
working and I want to make a couple of
changes for example I know that this is
probably not used or actually it's not
used so let's remove it so I removed a
using statement while at the same time
maybe I want to add an exclamation mark
over here so I made two kinds of changes
one where I change the string that's
visible to the user and then I removed
something that is basically just a clean
up now these two things are typically
things that you want into two separate
commits because while this affects the
UI of your program this one is
completely visible to only programmers
and you want to treat them individually
so what do you do let's save this file
if do a diff of course I see the type
two differences what I want to do is
that I want to commit them individually
even though they are in the same file so
what do I do is that instead of just
doing add I say add P or patch and what
this allows me to do is that git is
gonna ask me okay I see that you have
two changes in this file do you want to
commit this one and you say no what
about this you won't commit this one and
I say yes absolutely has commit that one
so now if I do get status you see that
my file is at the same time part of it
is staged and part of it is still in my
working directory and if I want to see
what's only staged I say get de the
thief - - cashed and that's what I've
staged and if I want to see what's in my
working directory I say just get if and
graphical get clients will also show
this so it's going to be pretty clear
what rest what you have staged and what
we have not staged so this point I can
say git commit commit and then I say I
changed the read line string and then at
this point I can just add the rest of
the last two apart commit even if there
is just one just to show you how it
works again so now we want to don't
commit this and say yes and then I say
commit removes and unused import
statement and then so then I have a
logically separated my commit and notice
that I didn't have to think about it as
I was editing my file it's something
that I did afterwards so this is a very
big difference between get and other
source control systems in that if you're
using subversion or TFS you know that to
do this kind of thing you need to think
ahead and do one change at a time check
in and then do the other change and you
kind of had to keep that stuff in your
head while in get I can just edit as I
want and at the time of commit then I
can split them up
so this frees me from having to think
about source control as I'm editing the
file which is something to keep in mind
so autonomous commits the next is the C
and it stands for compatible as it
commits are compatible in the sense that
they should not break the state of your
project so you should be able to cherry
pick to to pick a commit and apply it in
your branch without being afraid that
you should no brake tests or no longer
compile but how do you make sure that
every individual commit doesn't add any
errors well you have a couple of ways to
do that first one is to use the stash
so stash you probably know what it is
stash takes the files that are modified
in your working directory and saves them
separately and put them in a kind of a
different location called the stash now
I don't usually use the stash because
problem with the stash is that it tends
to grow over time and then you're kind
of select putting stuff in the closet
and then suddenly you open it up add
stuff you know comes at you some but in
this case I use the stash to verify that
my change do not break anything so for
example let me open up this file again
and let's make a let's make a change for
example let's remove this the public and
then let me open up another file for
example the project file
let's let's rename this to hello world
this is just a project file perfect so
now I have two modified files I want to
verify I want to commit to the program
just by itself and the change in the
process file just by itself because I
become it should be autonomous so how do
I verify that my change doesn't break
anything well I add my the file I want
to commit to the staging area so now
I've prepared my commit but I still have
a lot of files I still have a file
modified in my working directory how do
I get rid of that I say stash save and
then I pass the option keep index so
what this does is that exactly what it
says it's gonna stash my project file
that is in my working directory as
modified but it will not do anything
with water I already said I'm about to
commit so let's do that and you see that
now I just have my indexed mic my
state's file and my project file is
stashed away so at this point I can run
the tests I can run the build script and
I know that the only files that are in
my working directory are the files that
are about to be committed so if
everything works then I'm pretty I know
that it I haven't broken anything and
when when I'm done well as philosophers
commit this what did I do
oh yeah I removed a removes the public
key word good change and then I can
simply put back the changes from the
stash
we get - pop and now I have my practice
file back very powerful technique to use
something that I use all the time and
something that I've seen a lot of teams
do as well on an individual level but of
course this is adding a little bit of
work to your workflow let me just get
rid of that change this is adding of
some steps so what can you do if you
have already committed everything and
you haven't used this technique so how
can you ensure that everything that
every individual committed doesn't break
your software meet rebase again rebase
is a kind of a jack-of-all-trades in get
and get balance it does everything we
saw that it can fix the white space for
you and it can also help you ensure that
every individual commit doesn't break
your source code with something called
the exec option so what you can do is
basically say during a rebase I won't
get to execute a command that I pass
after each commit and how does it do
that well let me show you by turning it
into an interactive commit well we can
see the list of commits and so in this
case I don't have any tests
unfortunately but I do have a build
process Phi that I can build so what I'm
saying is that I want get to run the
that build after every commit which
commits well let's start from the
beginning so I'm gonna say rebase route
which means take all the commits that
are in this current branch and run does
not build so what it does is that as you
see it basically append this line after
every commit that I selected in the
range in this case everything
so what I have to do now is just save
this file and get is gonna run the build
automatically so the first one goes
through no problem second one fails as
you saw earlier so right now I am on the
exact commit that broke the build and I
can see that the problem is that the
console doesn't have a riddle Luna
method so this is just a typo but you
see that it is telling me the execution
of your program of your command has
failed and we are at t commit that added
introduce the error commit fall of 16 so
let's look at this commit and indeed
this is the commit that added the line
that created a problem so what can I do
now I can open this program this source
code file I can add what fix the problem
basically
let's take a look yeah I can even just
run the build script again just to make
sure that everything works then I can
stage it and then I don't want to create
a new commit but I want to basically
modify the committed I'm on right now so
I say git commit amend and if you don't
want to change the message you can
basically say no edit and now if I look
at the file I if I look at the commit I
just it's like the other never happened
so at this point I can say get to the
base continue and it will you know
continue on through all the others
running the build oh now we have another
problem but you have already seen the
drill so there is no point in doing it
again otherwise we'll be here till
tomorrow so just report everything so
rebase exact very good way to ensure
that every commit does not break yeah
is compatible next one is the eye and
that's incremental what's an incremental
commit well an incremental commit is a
commit that shows clearly the
progression you have made with your
changes what does it mean it means that
every commit should basically show you
your thought process as you went through
about your changes how do you ensure
that your commits are incremental well
you use an interactively base so let me
show you again let's say that I want to
push these latest three commits and what
while I'm here I can decide it you know
this one should come before that one and
because this is the progress that I've
made through my changes for example if
this was a this is a clean up and this
is the thing I want to do first then I
want to make a change that is actually
user related change and then maybe I
want well you know what this is also a
clean up so let's move it also before so
I've removed remove and changed and
basically just I'm just reordering in my
commit before I share them to show some
kind of logical progression this means
taking care of your history the last one
is the DNA stands for documented so yeah
when commit messages commit messages do
matter they matter a lot so let's make
sure that they explain not necessarily
just what changed but why it did and let
me just show you what I mean so when you
are writing a commit message there is a
well-defined format for how commits
should be formatted
and the it's like this the first line is
called the subject and it should be at
the most 50 characters so and if you're
using something like well if you're
using a get GUI it's gonna show you and
on the command line if you're using
something like vim if I write more text
here at so you see that it changed color
at some point this is the 50 51
character so it's clearly showing me
that the first line should be at the
most 50 characters so it should build
this summary if you want to provide more
information about to change
you should leave an empty line over here
and then you have the so called body
where you can explain why this changed
and provide any more resources for
example links to other commits and and
etc one quick tip here if you are doing
per programming in your team and you
want to record who was involved in the
pair programming session now git only
records one author so what you can do
and I've seen some teams do that to
great effect is that day at the end of
the commit message they write the name
of the names of the people involved in
the in the paragraph so for example yeah
you get a point
bar and Buzz
so you're basically named everyone who
was involved in the pair programming
session and you record it as part of the
commit message but you do it in a
consistent format so you can easily
later find out who was involved in this
change pretty nice thing to do which
doesn't take a lot of effort so
these are the acid commits so to recap
as he commits are autonomous they're
compatible they are incremental and they
are documented easy to remember the next
category of things you can do
individually is to automate now git has
a bunch of features to get stuff done
quicker so one thing to be effective is
to let it do the work for you the first
thing is having something called the
earliest functions so you know that you
can create aliases and get to kind of
shorten the command so instead of saying
check out for example you can write Co
and so I can say git Co feature instead
of git checkout so this is no pretty
pretty nice but it doesn't stop there
you can associate entire shelf functions
to a to an alias so one of my favorite
ones that I came up with a few years ago
and I've been using ever since is what I
call the undo alias so what does it do
undo basically defines a function called
F so this means that the alias should
run a shell command that's the
exclamation mark then I define a shell
function called F doesn't really matter
what it's called and the body of the
function is I do a reset to the previous
I know this looks cryptic but this
resets my current branch to the previous
commit in the ref log ref log being the
history of every commit that happened in
your branch and this is the parameter
that I pass to the function and then at
the end of the function declaration I
just invoke it immediately afterwards so
this allows me for example if let me
just commit
an empty commit so no changes so let's
make Amit a commit B and then let me
just use my alias to show you just the
last four commits so let's say that I
want to undo these two commits I can use
my undo Elias to say get undo and then
pass
how many commits ago how many keys do
you want to undo that means how many
times you want to undo - so it's like
Dramamine
it's like pressing ctrl Z twice one two
and now I use the wrong one and now I
don't have a a B anymore
so alias functions very powerful way to
associate complex you know shell
functions to your aliases and speed up
your workflow the next one is what I
call out to this and out of that so this
one I won't show you because I don't I'm
running out of time
otherwise I have lots of the things to
tell you so you might know that too when
you're doing a rebase if you have some
modified files in your working directory
it will tell you know you can't rebase
because you have files
well what out of starch does is a pack
exactly what it says if you're doing a
rebase and you have modified files it
will automatically stash them away do
the rebase and then put them back in
much like we did before we'd keep index
but it will do it automatically how to
squash this one is interesting let's say
that you are working on your changes and
then you realized that a few commits ago
you should have included another change
for example let's say that in this one I
wanted to do something else but I'm
already made two commits afterwards so I
can't easily amend it so what I can do
is that I can make the change so for
example
yeah let's do whatever let's remove the
exclamation mark so now I have a change
that I know I wanted to include here
instead so what do I do instead of
committing it until new commit well I
started by staging it of course and then
I say commit fix up and then I pass it
the the commit ID of the one that I want
to include this change into so of course
I can find it like this but an even
quicker way is just just by saying
commit fix-up : - looks like a
disappointed emoji and here YUM I can
just enter a portion of the commit
message so for example let's say unused
and the it is gonna find the committed
that contains this word guess the commit
hash and create a new commit that starts
with fix-up and then the rest of the
commit message so now I have this what I
do next is that I do a rebase an
interactively base remember like we did
for reordering and then I can just go
back a few and it will this commit will
automatically be moved right underneath
the one that it should be thick squashed
into and at this point I can just save
and it's gonna do do the squash of
course this comes really in handy if you
have multiple commits that you want to
squash into earlier ones because they
will automatically move into the right
place and now I have the squash
commit and this is what out squashed us
so lots of built-in useful features that
you can enable and tap into the next one
is client-side hooks now there are a you
can write that will automatically run on
your machine when some events occur so
for example the pre-commit will fire
just before you are creating the commit
and you can use it to validate for
example that you don't have an invalid
whitespace the neck the other one will
fire also before the committee's created
but will allow you to for example
validate the commit message so I have
these files they live in the dot kids
directory called hooks there are a bunch
of them I have one called commit message
that I've implemented and this is just a
shell function that basically reads
the it will receive the entire commit
message as a parameter and then I can
just verify that it's shorter than the
designed designated 50 characters and if
it isn't I get a warning and the
possibility to modify it so let me show
you how it works let's create an empty
commit just not not to have to make a
change and then I can write a really
long message that is definately longer
than 50 characters and then I get this
warning that says hey your line should
be 50 characters but it was 72 do you
want to modify the message or just
commit it if I press yes then you see
that I can cut it at the right point
I never press no I can just ignore it
so client-side hooks something that
effective teams definitely distribute to
everyone and this speeds up their
individual workflows because they catch
errors before they get pushed into the
common repository
and this is the last of the individual
workflows tips the next ones are related
to teams workflows so three categories
here as well let's get right into it
the first one is related to branching
now I won't talk about in the specific
get workflows like for example get up
flow or get flow these are ideas and
things to consider and think about as
you are deciding which workflow switch
suits your particular team and your
particular project so the first thing to
think about is being aware that there
are different kinds of branches and what
do I mean by that I mean that branches
come in two flavors there are long
running branches and there are topic
branches now long running branches is
exactly what it sounds like they live
for up to the entire life of the project
your TP every process has at least one
long-running branch and there is master
while topic branches and atopic branches
are short-lived and they are usually
focused on a particular task for example
a bug fix or a feature now so master is
an example of a long-running branch and
a feature is an example of a topic
branch now topic branches typically
typically get merged into the
long-running branch and afterwards they
disappear so what you are left with is
the fact that some work was done in
parallel to the long-running branch now
there is another way - there is another
kind of categorization you can do with
branches and that is public branches and
private branches now again
this is pretty straightforward but it
being a distributed source control
system you have a repository that is
shared your canonical repository where
everybody pushes to and that will leave
something on a server like on github or
on Azure DevOps and then you have your
local personal repository that are
working on now a branch that exists in a
shared repo is considered a public one
that is that is a branch where multiple
people are pushing commits into a lock a
private branch is one that exists only
on your machine so they are create they
live and die on your computer they're
never published anywhere those are
private branches now long-running
branches are typically public because of
course they are branches where people
collaborate so they need to live on the
shared repo topic branches are usually
private those are the branches that you
create on your machine to keep your own
work organized of course this is not the
only way you can have private
long-running branches so branches that
you keep alive for a long time and you
can have topic branches where multiple
people are collaborating so they are
public topic branches now not all
combinations are considered equal
long-running
public branches definitely yes they are
good and they're necessary the same goes
for private topic branches absolutely
use those however avoid having
long-running private branches why
because the longer you keep a branch to
yourself the harder it is is going to be
later to merge it back into the public
branch you're gonna run into lots of
conflicts the longer you keep it to
yourself because nobody knows what's
happening in that branch and the long
running published Brown public branch is
gonna move a
so avoid having a long run in private
branches the same goes for public topic
branches now if you have to you have to
but in general a topic branch is better
used by an individual or if you're doing
part programming not multiple people but
having people collaborate in a
distributed fashion on a topic branch
leads to a lot of complicated scenarios
where people are maybe rewriting the
history they are rebasing
they are handling it in different ways
so absolutely can work but as a general
a rule of thumb
avoid public topic branches this means
that the guideline becomes be
conservative with having long-running
public branches don't have too many of
them and be liberal with the private
topic branches create as many as you
want the next one is related to merging
now this means let your branches decide
how you want to merge them now knowing
that there are these categories of
branches long-running topic public and
private depending on what they are there
should be merged differently now you
know that in case there are two ways to
merge there is something called the true
merge which the one we did earlier that
is you're creating a merge commit the
other one is doing a rebase where you
are moving commits and then you're
merging by just doing a fast-forward now
if you have a public branch that you
want to merge into another public branch
it should most definitely use a merge
commit you want public branches that
everybody see to be visible when they
converge when you want to merge the
public branch into a private one though
like if you're having your work in
progress and you want to keep it updated
with what happens in the public branch
then you absolutely want to rebase why
let's so for example a public branch
could be a perfect
that you want to merge into master and a
public branch master immerse into your
working promise so what do I mean if
this is a public ranch called master and
this is a pull request there is also
public because I want to have it code
reviewed so it gets pushed to the shared
repo and it becomes a public branch
where other people can comment on when I
want to merge my pull request into
master I want to do it with a merge
commit why because and then it gets
deleted if there is a problem later on I
discover a problem with what I merged it
is much easier to revert a merge commit
with a new commit you see the the
inverse of an M is a W this is a normal
get notation so two by reverting a merge
you can effectively undo everything that
was done in the pull request in one
single commit this is of course much
harder if I had rebased
my pull request on master moved master
forward and then if there is a problem
in the pull request I need to revert
every individual commit by itself of
course this is especially if you
discover it later on when there are more
commits happening afterwards after F in
this case it gets even trickier to
revert individual ones and determine
which one was problematic so another
case public and private branch you want
to merge them and you want to merge the
sorry the public branch into the private
one it is your work in progress if you
do it through a merge instead of a
rebase and then later you want to merge
your work in progress into master you
see what happens there double merge now
if you do this enough that's why you
want to rebase instead if you want to do
if you do this enough what happens is
that you have a history that looks like
this we
lots and lots of merges that just don't
make any sense because you merged a pipe
a public branch into a private one this
is called the guitar hero history and
why is it called guitar hero because it
looks like this even sometimes called
get hero you want
a history that is clean and that doesn't
have anymore merge commits than it has
to the last tip or technique that you
can do within your team is to map your
branches to your release environments
and that means basically knowing where
your branches are going in which
environment that they are going so let's
say that this is the master branch and
this is the develop branch those are two
long-running branches one is mapped to a
QA environment where every commits get
pushed to some kind of environment where
it can be verified the master branch is
it represents the stable version of your
software that means when you are merging
the work that comes from develop that
has been tested you want to push it out
to production so it can be used to you
by your users so you see I have a clear
mapping between my develop branch goes
to test and QA and master goes to
production and of course you can also do
different kinds of deployments here on
the develop branch you can develop every
commit automatically and in that case
you will do something called continuous
deployment while you probably don't want
value of course you can and there are
many teams doing it but you can push
every commit that happens in master
automatically to production but what's
more common is to have it master be in a
state that can be deployed but have it
be a manual step so at this point you
are doing continuous delivery
so you see mapping knowing where your
branches are going and mapping them
directly to an environment
really helps collaboration and really
helps getting the most out of your
source control system to basically help
your team deal with the lifecycle
management of your software so I'm
running out of time
so let's wrap it up I told you that
effective teams they have workflows that
are divided into two categories
individual workflows where the first one
was a configure environment take care of
crust crafting your history by creating
asset commit and then let it do the work
for you by automating as much as
possible of your workflow the other kind
kind of work for us are the team
workflows that is stuff to think about
when you are deciding how you want to
handle branching and merging in your
team so that means being aware of what
kinds of branching you have long-running
topic public and private and then base
your merged strategies based on what
branches are you are merging and the
next one is having a clear mapping
between your branches and your
environments where you are releasing
your software and with that I'm at the
end of this presentation I want to just
let you know that if you want are
interested in more on this kind of
techniques and ideas I have a process
course out called advanced key tips and
tricks this requires that you know I
have a fundamental understanding of how
it works but here is the link and with
that I want to say thank you that for
for watching and I think I have some
time to answer questions I haven't
looked at the site if there are any so I
have two questions let me just open it
up
sorry yeah so the first one is I haven't
fully understood what keep index in
stash saved us can you verify so what it
does is that it takes all the modified
files in your working directory and it
stashes them away however it won't touch
anything that has already been States so
that's why it says keep index and this
allows you to get rid of all the
modified files stash them away and then
have only your staged file be in the
working directory and then you can run
your tests and verify that what you are
about to commit actually doesn't break
anything afterwards you create the
commit and then you on stage your
modified files
so hopefully this answer the question
Thomas has get aliases
I prefer saving my changes when undoing
as Analia Swiper equals and then there
is a a function a comment
yeah well this this is definitely a way
to do it I see that you are using the
exclamation mark to basically whatever
comes off to what's gonna be run as a
shell command and then you are using the
double ampersand to say if this command
succeeds then executes automatic
automatically execute the second one
followed by a third one this is
absolutely a good way to do it if you
don't want to write a function the
reason to write a function is that if
you want to pass arguments to your alias
like I did get undo with the number two
this won't let you accept arguments but
if you write a shell function then you
have dollar one dollar two dollar three
doors are the arguments that you can
pass to the alia so in my case I can say
get undo for and it will do the
operation for four commits
so that's why you want to use so if you
want to use arguments define a function
if you don't need arguments definitely
chain your commands like this
yeah
are there any more questions
you
nope
okay thank you very much for watching
and enjoy the rest of your day